five-point game pardon three yet another  one this is  [Applause]  [Music]  gotta hustle it across the chick turns  it over they don't call the kick and  harden ties the game at 125  it's a kid Walker  [Applause]  finally picked up by Chris Paul who does  have five five  [Applause]  four seconds for conflicts starts as  drive floats it up and in  Valanciunas with one tenth of a second  the entire night  has been huge with offensive rebound  especially here in the second half any  shots that  he has not put on the play at all  you see them at the air ball he's able  to locate it quicker than capella  [Applause]  now houston gonna miss it you miss  you're gonna miss it  yes